hey girl do you have an exposed position
because I want to slide my Rook into
your back rank meet you he's doing well
he's like a chess icon he's wealthy he's
successful he dresses well but he's five
too
yeah he's almost he's almost there
I'm 6'1 by the way
190. the year before he was a 25-20
rated Grandmaster at the age of 1617
that's good but it ain't great better
than you yeah boy no guys Levy Levy is
also unbiased Levy's career was not made
by chess.com Levy's career was not made
by Hikaru rating him promoting his
YouTube channel
Levy's career and success has absolutely
nothing to do with chess.com whatsoever
that is why he is unbiased in all of his
opinions
are completely honest
and unbiased and are just what he
personally thinks